hey guys how's it going so today we're
at YouTube space and I'm extremely
excited because I just played Mario Kart
with cup quick and Martin garrix now
you're probably wondering Justin why are
you playing video games with Martin
garrix he's actually working on a song
that is gonna be the soundtrack of III
for YouTube live this year so I'm so
excited for you guys to hear it let's go
watch us play some Mario Kart and please
don't judge my gameplay I'm gonna have
to blame this all on my Kart selection
and toad just not performing well it's
clearly not my fault this is the most
random collab I know right so we're
excited because Martin isn't doing a
track for e3 which most of you guys know
what III is and we're so excited because
we all just got a preview of it
Thanks what else do you have coming up
this year my new single is that line
lies in the world
then I've got a new sing with bebe Rexha
coming up afterwards points of new music
yes a most important way we're playing
Mario Kart now we did one round on their
Channel and I don't even want to talk we
just don't warm up it was a warm-up
we're saying are we doing one 50s did
you know what it's doing here one no I'm
excited this is a big very fun
I keep hearing the phrase all the way
ahead and I'm just like yeah me too I'm
not worse than this one so uh I'm gonna
say no I'm gonna be most parties took
them a little bit better I know they hit
the booze into the booth I already feel
faster but yeah I want to be the 150 oh
yeah oh I don't think all the computers
are gonna be really good but it just
makes you say I don't know for me this
is normal oh yeah oh no what who threw
that me yeah
that red shell almost down oh my god
blue shells
Susan particle you're gonna feel a
little bit better
man I've got chocolate all right oh wait
oh I'm not trying to hate you behind me
okay resin for you I'm trying to keep
the peace over here I didn't know good I
thought they were trying to get me dang
it who's in first I'm friends of friends
down double-barreling come on you can
come on they're behind you
get out of here
oh let's get out Nana what
oh my god that was good we're all so far
let's get that boost yeah patek this
boosts yeah yeah let's go
oh it burns Oh March are your tunes
oh shoot oh man you got me oh my god Oh
this is hard no one Santa can be made
here Jacob here there's a computer um
I'm gonna die on no what's the bananas
terribly wrong seven no what about it
does anyone of us in first know did you
Marius so good what the hell right
behind it I can't catch up Sofia won't
we G take no oh all right I'll take
third
no this is unacceptable see let's start
a computer
yeah yeah we yeah yeah Robin no we
should target for next let's get her no
I love the strike I hate this one I feel
bad at this one oh man I'm in the water
I'm sloppiness right now me
makes me cry Mizar lottery now do
quantum crying for another lemonade okay
I'm in six ready all that you say about
that
let's go my second place yeah wasn't
first me what's right hey it whoa there
was a boat I'm sorry
telling me oh just gonna see you oh no
I'm not gonna hate you don't worry keep
the peace okay honestly if you have to
do it do it on the friend shell and I
just shot it but hit the crap oh man I
just keep dragging on down and six
oh come on it's somebody hits I'll lead
you just pack me up and I am us in a
crowd no she needs to go down oh oh the
whole time really oh I don't know guys
actually I used to be really good at
this game I played yesterday and I gave
him first every time it's okay it's okay
we all hold our friggin have another my
bond right [ __ ] it towed sucks well just
know my
Oh oh don't blame the table regarding or
not anymore
I keep her skiing this guy I know I did
where oh oh no I just try to get on the
ramp on the car
oh shoot got it on I got not the helps
almost a cars cheating yeah I know he's
like yeah you I don't really play like
no sorry
I know you're killing all of us I can't
we just eat like nature is gonna be the
challenge
oh yeah Oh what oh my god it's on you
there's a red [ __ ] Oh God
I deserve it oh no you stupid why would
you take two of those m1 goodbye soon
apply I'm gonna I'm gonna catch up until
what will please you no thanks so that
bigots oh they're not so much more I
need collect these I'm your buddy the
coins until especially in this time oh
wow give it road I mean bowels are just
passed me up what yeah there's no way
I'm winning this
oh boy oh sure Oh God have a seat bullet
how great oh wait wait oh my god Oh God
look at this are you kidding me Oh just
steer home I start out strong
Oh
good job man that's awesome
g-g-g-gia ma'am sweetie
regula soon oh how should I tell him
should I Texan yeah sure enema No maybe
I'll tweet it yes not working out walnut
yeah maybe so there you have it surely
loci all happy bow
well that was really fun yeah always a
blast what you guys are playing
something else again Ibiza
yeah people yeah we're making some plans
oh no that's it so we'll see you guys
later
thanks for playing guys see you guys
here I suppose you're watching hope you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you go
check out cup quakes channel because she
has a video of us also playing on 100cc
we actually played that first and then
we came over here and played the 150 I
thought I'd be a little bit better at
150 but definitely didn't happen check
all of the link in the descriptions for
tips channel and be sure to check out
Martin's new song line in the wild which
is out now it is such a good song I
can't if you guys hear III song and
vlogging with the DSLR and it's really
heavy I'll see you guys later bye we're
back with another iPhone 7 video there
hasn't really been that much news but
with WWDC right around the corner it's
probably a good time to maybe chat about
it